what's going on everybody this is mike
of munch development
coming to you with another coding tech
original today we're going to be
discussing
view all right and we're going to try to
convince you to add
view to your toolbox we're going to give
you five reasons
why you should consider adding view to
your toolbox all right
so without further ado let's get started
so i'm going to go in overview
and then we're going to get into a
little of the demonstration
of an app that you know points some of
this stuff out and then we'll conclude
all right so
the five reasons all right here the
summary fast onboarding
data binding the view way the
the advantages of being a younger
sibling and then the job
market alright so fast onboarding fast
onboarding
what do i mean by that well even the
view docsig
i'm going to go over here the view docs
say that if you already know
html css and javascript you read the
guide and start building things
in no time all right so and you can see
that even in the code that you know
is given to you right out of the box
you'll have an html template over here
right it's very similar to angular
except that angular puts you know
that into its own file you can also do
that in view but view puts it
puts everything into one file but it's
just html right even your class names
you'll notice that uh even in the class
names are
class not class name if you're a react
developer all right and just full
disclosure i am a
react developer so i'm and i'm not
moving to view anytime soon but i do see
the value and benefits
of vue and i just want to try to
convince you to add it to your toolbox
and i'm going to be doing the same
all right so you've got a style sheet
here right a scoped style sheet that's
going to be you know basically for your
entire document
all right and then if you're looking at
this home
view view component i've also got a
script tag right in here right so if you
know html
if you know css and you know javascript
you can get right into building
view applications alright so you need
those three and the view docs
all right data binding the second reason
data binding okay
so there's multiple ways right you've
got the inline data binding here
right very similar to angular it pulls
from angular in that regard
uh this is a computed property here that
i'm pulling from the view store
that i created and we'll get to that in
point three
uh but i'm this is just in line here i
want to see this in my template
i i want that count and i'm just anytime
that that updates
it's going to update for me again we'll
see this in the demonstration
um another way that i look at my little
currency
uh calculator here right is the model
right binding to the model right so this
is a value on my state it's called the
base currency
and i'm binding to that whenever this
changes
uh i want to see that change updated in
my
input right my text input field okay so
those are two ways that you can use you
can use model
binding and you can use inline binding
all right
and they're all reactive right so
whenever something changes this stuff is
going to change
okay that's a very important point
uh for view right they pull that from
angular and it's a it's a bonus
um in view as well all right this is
number three this is the view way this
is the way
right okay view unlike react
has uh one way
preferred to do routing state management
and testing
okay you don't have to worry about
knowing several different
uh in order to get a job you don't know
have to know about uh
several different state management uh
tools or several different routing tools
like react navigation or react router
which one are you gonna use what's the
new hotness that is coming out that's
trying to vie for um standing in the
react community
with vue all of that is
out of the window right you've got a
view router you
use it inside of your view application
you got view state management
use it inside of your application and
you got view testing
use it inside of your application right
that has some some merit and value again
because
onboarding is a lot faster you don't
have to worry about
knowing multiple different uh
streams of you can get into a react
application and it could have
you could be using context api or react
with redux or react with
uh redux saga react with redux thunk you
know
you could be using a whole bunch of
different stuff not with view views like
we got estate management it's called
view x use it
right we've got a router it's called
view router use it
okay and then we you know oh enzyme
react testing library
stop right there view testing library
right
okay so there's some benefit to that
right if you're like me your favorite
planet from star wars is mandalore
you like that right this is the way okay
so that's one of the benefits of using
view
number three so number four the
advantage of being a younger sibling
right you get the best of both worlds
vue came up after react and angular they
saw some of the challenges that bro
both brought they saw some of the
successes and wins that both
uh that the react library and the
angular framework brought in
and they tried to combine the best of
both worlds right
while adding their own flavor to it you
get some of those
some of those things that are beneficial
in angular you get to bring them in
some of those things that are beneficial
in react you get to bring them in and
the cool thing about view is that you
can use them or not
right view can be incrementally adopted
across your application you can add view
the script tag to an existing vanilla
javascript
framework a javascript app and you can
start using some view
uh compo you know view view uh
components in there
right again so you get the best of both
worlds right whereas react lets you
choose
everything out of the boxes like we just
do view components you do whatever you
want on that we got react dom react
native like what
we just presentational presentational
right angular's like
everything you when you start you
everything you get everything
and that's it right you deal with it all
right views like if you want to use it
you don't have you can use it if not if
not
it tries to stay performant in that way
uh keeping the bundle size small
only using what uh the things that you
need
from the uh from the framework all right
and then the job market
okay so the job market when you see a
view job you know that it's
you're going to be using certain things
it's view right
if you see a react job you may say oh
this i need a senior react developer
who and you're like cool i'm a senior
but i need uh three years of next gs
oops right well i don't have three i'm
i'm an expert react developer but i
don't have three years of nexus right
or you're like well we have this this
system written in my backs
well i've only been using react with
redux
you're like well somebody else is going
to get that because they may have been
using my backs or
we're only using context api okay well
i don't know what to do about that right
uh there's a lot of different things
that you that come into play when it
comes to a react job right
uh not so with view view you're like hey
we're using view
uh there may be some things that you
won't know but you should be able to
pick them up quickly because
the router the state management and the
testing library
we're using the the standards okay this
is the view way and that helps you when
you're searching for jobs right
so you know what to expect okay so let
me give you a little bit of
demonstration of these things that i
talked about all right so i built this
little app
uh i've been not this part i didn't
build this part in 30 minutes but the
routing
the state management and uh and you know
the data binding part
and then i just dropped this other thing
in that i built before
into it all right so the router all
right let's go over that first so i've
got three routes here
all right so let me go over here i'm new
i'm doing something new with my
with my being over here let me i don't
like it i already don't like it
bar all right so shy bar i wanted like
sidebar to the left i'm moving that i'm
already moving it
i don't like it let me change it back
but
for purposes of this i do not like it
all right so
let me go to the main.js all right first
let's go to the router all right so the
index router
right i'm pulling off a view router the
create web history and the create router
and then i set my array of routes right
the path the name and then the component
right so home about and currency
calculator are my components
okay i create a router the history i'm
going to use the create web history
right and it gives you right the single
page application is basically going to
create an html5 history
and you give it the routes that's it and
you've got a router
okay that's it all right that's a simple
you you create a router that simply now
to do more in-depth thing
in-depth things you can go into the
documentation and you can see it there
but to create a simple router i got view
router
and i'm good i'm ready to go right okay
so i import that router uh
from my router file into my main.js
i'm also creating my store from
my uh main.js you know okay you know
what i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show
you how
how uh us developers think like you know
what this is so wrong
that i did not do that all right i'm
gonna do this
all right you get to see this this is
this is what this is uh
so i'm gonna do this i'm gonna go over
here and i'll say i didn't
i wasn't consistent all right and i'm
going to export the store
all right export default
store okay so i'm going to come back
over here
and i'm going to be good i'm going to
make this make this a smaller component
store from store
all right now okay create store is not
defined it's because i got to go put it
in there
all right boom i want to be good right
see look you get to see now this is this
file is a lot smaller and i'm getting
compiled successfully down here all
right
so create app i'm creating my app and
i'm using this middleware i'm using my
router and i'm using my store and then
i'm mounting that into my
um my div on on the uh
index all right the app div okay so
we're talking about the store let's go
to the store all right so from view x
create store my state function returns
what this is my initial state
count zero exchange rates nothing then i
have my mutations
okay i can i can call out these
mutations and and um
mutate state uh from this um
from these functions okay so sort of
like your reducers all right
uh and then in actions i can i can
dispatch actions and uh
wait for their uh for the actions to
complete
right this is sort of like redux funk um
returning promises here right
i can return this promise and then i can
commit this
uh mutation to the store all right so
i'm calling this cc this function set
exchange rates
and then i give it the rates that i just
massaged and got from this exchange
rates
link all right and i'm just sitting
there waiting on that now how would i
use this
okay so let's show you all right in the
about
i'm going to go to i'm going to the
about the home page first
right so this is my increment and my
decrement right and i'm going to show
you what they're doing
okay so let's go to the home component
basically what i'm saying is on
on click right this is this the the on
click this is how you
handle events uh in view on inline
right so the click and then i want to do
prevent default that's what that's
saying here
all right and i want to say go to the
store and commit the decrement
mutation or commit this to the store
this decrement with the payload of one
and that's what i'm doing here right and
then i want to do the same thing
on this side increment one all right
and i'm just i'm just committing that
action of committing that mutation to
the store
and that's what's calling uh that's
calling this
right here increment state
one right and that's what that's what's
going on right it's just saying i want i
want to call that
and i want to increment decrement okay
and then remember we talked about this
computed property all right where this
is just waiting
anytime the store changes that this uh
the state changes this specific value
count
that's this is returning that to this
function and that computed property is
sitting there waiting and that's what's
changing this
all right now if i go to the about page
because i'm using the same state in the
same store
i should see four here right uh and i
can do that whenever i change it it's
going to change there
right because i'm changing it here and
it's the same store
that this is getting the data from okay
all right
so real quick that was that was simple
right
again we gotta i mean i've got got my
styles and stuff in there
okay uh but we see my router's working
right and i'll show you here the uh app
view
right you got a router links right this
is to the
to that to the home page this is to the
about page and this is to the currency
page
and those routes map exactly here these
paths that
the router sitting there looking for
right so we created router links to
those pages
okay and then we just kind of have our
router view sitting there right so
underneath that that's we're gonna just
everything that's underneath um the
application
basically the application is is here
right this is
this is the view the the main view of
the application okay
so we're gonna go back now let's get
into that currency
uh calculator a little bit right just a
little bit because i'll leave that for
you all to kind of play around with
right i don't want this video to be too
long about 15 minutes at the most okay
so what i'm doing here this is the one
thing i want to show you a couple of
things i want to show you right
is this the ability to watch values okay
um so right out of the box i can say i
want to i get this from view i want to
create this well first i want to create
this
uh reactive state okay so that it's
sitting there waiting for changes and
updates the changes on this page right
so that's what reactive is doing
um and this is the initial state that
i'm giving it
okay and then i have these watch this
watch function
that sits there waiting for values on
state to change and and i can perform
some
uh some uh mutations uh
of some actions when that happens okay
so let's see let's see something's going
on here it's not
it's not like i'm gonna refresh that and
see what happens all right
grab the data maybe it's no it's still
working okay
cool all right there it is all right
that's because that that heroku app had
to wake up
all right so so i'm waiting for my base
exchange rate to change and when that
changes that's this right here my base
exchange rate
when that changes i want to uh set the
base currency okay so if i change this
to euros well that should change that's
changing the base currency
all right same thing over here if i
change this to dollars
that should change that to dollars
that's basically what this what these
two watchers are doing
so i don't have to do anything extra i'm
just sitting there
watch these when these when these values
change you go and change the currency
value okay
these are just some basic basic
javascript functions you know that are
changing things
but this is the other thing i want to
show you before uh we we head out for
this video okay
so i'm grabbing from the store
the exchange rates and i'm saying okay
if there's nothing in there go and get
them
right so dispatch that's that action
that i talked about we're dispatching
that action
here on the store to get exchange rates
that's this
right i'm telling i'm calling it here
and just it's going to wait for that to
finish
and then it's going to commit and set
whatever rate i get back from the fetch
in there and then now i can use these
rates
here to create my drop downs over here
so i'm just getting all the rates
right and then that's how i create the
drop downs right
but it's saving me time so that i don't
have to go and fetch it every time now
whenever i go back to home come back to
about go back to currency calculator
it's already there now obviously i could
do some other things in there by saving
the values i could save these on to the
store so that you know when you came
back would be exactly like you left it
you can do a lot of that stuff as well
but
those are some of the you know really
cool things about view i think i covered
most of that stuff
yeah so i even got a computed property
here of get exchange rates and i'm using
that up there as i
oh yeah that's what i wanted to show you
true again um
you know you got your your v4 vf those
things that you can like v class
you've got all of those uh v v dash
right elsif html like all of these
things that you can that you're used to
seeing
it's not v class v class is not in there
it's just class uh oh it's it's um
this is how you can set uh conditional
classes right uh
yeah semicolon class okay so or that
colon class all right so you got those
the same thing that you have in angular
they pulled a lot of stuff from the best
from both worlds right
so uh i'm gonna leave you there but i
hope that you've been able to see that
vue is a very viable competitor
uh in the javascript framework you know
ecosystem world or whatever
right it may be something that you may
want to add to your tool bag
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe alright what would you like to
see next the code will be down
in the description uh again just
interact with us we love hearing from
you
uh we're trying to build the coding tech
youtube channel with more
original uh content um yeah so
uh and then the last thing do you agree
with my view right
about view okay so let me know down in
the comments all right so happy holidays
to you all
and also happy coding all right